alexeï navalni comparaît devant la
justice russe l'opposant et ce matin
devant le tribunal de moscou il est
accusé d'avoir violé son contrôle
judiciaire dans une affaire qui remonte
à 2014
alex de la vanille qui sera également
jugé vendredi mais cette fois pour
diffamation d'un ancien combattant de la
seconde guerre mondiale un délit
passible d'amendé ou de prison pour
rappel l'opposant 44 ans a été arrêté il
ya deux semaines à son retour
d'allemagne il était en convalescence
après son emprise son empoisonnement
présumé en août pour comprendre les
enjeux de ce procès on retrouve en
direct de moscou notre correspondant
antoine théâtre antoine bonjour vous
êtes devant le tribunal de moscou vous
suivez pour nous le premier procès d'
alexeï navalni
oui cela fait trois heures que
l'audience a démarré alexeï navalni
tente de répondre aux accusations de la
nuit de l'administration pénitentiaire
qui lui reproche de ne pas avoir
respecté à 60 reprises les conditions de
son contrôle judiciaire
pour rappel en 2014 avec senna vanni a
été condamné à trois ans et demi de
prison avec sursis dans une affaire de
détournement de fonds et
l'administration judiciaire veut
aujourd'hui que cette peine ces baisses
de prix de prison avec sursis soit
commuée en peine de prison ferme alors
nous avons également vu passer a noté
passé plusieurs véhicules avec des
plaques diplomatiques entrer dans
l'enceinte de ce tribunal
ce sont donc des représentants
d'ambassades étrangères qui assiste en
ce moment même au procès dans l'excès
d'un vanille ce cahier immédiatement
dénoncé le ministère russe des affaires
étrangères qui considère qu'il s'agit là
d'une interférence d'une ingérence dans
des affaires internes à la russie le
kremlin a également réagi l'a fait
savoir que ce serait une bêtise si l'ue
veut l'union européenne viendrait à
conditionner ses relations avec la
russie
en fonction des résultats de cette
affaire navalni quant au soutien de
cette de l'opposant russe qui ont promis
de se rassembler de se rassembler aux
abords de ce tribunal
il faut dire que toute cette zone autour
du tribunal est complètement verrouillé
complètement bouclé par les forces de
police une présence policière très
importante et ce depuis tôt ce matin
résultats et ceux ils sont cantonnés un
parc qui se trouve à quelques centaines
de mètres du tribunal et il ya déjà eu
plus de 200 arrestations dont les rangs
des soutiens de l'opposant russe merci
en tant qu'aéroport toutes ces
précisions